a lot of our philosophers have what
would seem to us a very counterintuitive
idea of how to break patterns among the
key things they will say our rituals now
we often find rituals to be a bad thing
um some of them are okay you know a
ritual presumably is a nice thing and a
family get-together on a holiday but the
idea of doing lots of rituals of the
course of a day strikes us as archaic
it's things that traditional people used
to have to do and we tend to think it's
good for us that we don't have to do it
because if we're going to be sincere and
true and authentic to ourselves we don't
want rituals that tell us what to do
well but again let's suppose for a
second that perhaps our Philosopher's
you're onto something that we are just
these patterns creatures and these
patterns are potentially very dangerous
so how do we break them that's why you
do rituals what rituals do is they force
you for a brief moment to become a
different person
and interact with those around you in a
different way so for that brief moment
suddenly you're no longer repeating the
same old patterns you're doing something
else and what they argued was it's that
break that really matters let me give
you an absurdly mundane example a
typical of one in America is we see
someone that we sort of know and we say
you know we're going through the usual
day our anxieties fears and angers blah
blah blah our typical patterns in this
language and then we see someone we say
oh hey how's it going and the other
person goes oh pretty good how are you
was it oh yeah I'm pretty good too and
then we walk off now if you think about
it you might think well it's sort of
silly that we do that because that's
inauthentic I'm actually not feeling
pretty good right then but if you think
of it as a ritual it's actually a very
good thing to do and we should even do
it more fully because then what you're
doing is you're breaking out of that
standard set of patterns of the ways
you're going about the day for that
brief moment you suddenly and I'll use
their language you enter a ritual space
you're connecting with someone things
are going well you're connecting with
this person perfectly it breaks you out
of those patterns and then if you're
doing that sort of thing these little
seemingly meaningless rituals over the
course of a day consistently you're
breaking yourself out of these little
patterns and opening up other
possibilities and they would argue that
is why ritual matters it breaks us out
of patterns we enter it to an AZ of
space we act as if we are a different
person with a different set of emotions
interacting with those around us in a
different way and that is over time how
you break these patterns so this may
seem somewhat odd if we're entering into
a ritual which of course it gives us
different patterns of interaction how is
that actually going to improve the fact
that we are doing other patterns outside
of it
well here's their full argument if we
are going throughout our days they would
argue simply repeating these same
patterns interacting with people based
on our same standard responses our same
standard habits what ritual will do is
break those patterns they will give you
new patterns but the argument they would
make is it's not that the ritual
patterns are the right one it's the
break they care about now let's go back
to the greeting example I see someone Oh
things are fine I connect for that brief
moment then of course that person passes
and I return to my usual patterns in
their language I return I leave the
ritual space but the point is you keep
going back in other words you keep doing
these little rituals over and over again
the way you greet someone the way you
shift a language if you're talking to
someone and it's those little breaks
those little shifts that make a
difference over the course of a day then
where would that take you well where it
takes you they would argue is over time
you begin to get a sense of the ways
that little things you do are affecting
others that these patterns we're playing
out or bringing out certain responses
and those around us and you begin to
gain the power to alter those so you
have a standard argument that one always
has with one's partner and that person
says something it makes me angry that
makes that person angry and we go the
same
we know this so well so all you do is
you take these ideas seriously begin to
slightly shift that begin to slightly
shift the standard pattern you fall into
and even if there's not a set ritual
that gives you the ability to do so you
gain the same thing by simply doing a
little break so you hold your body
slightly differently use a slightly
different tone of voice you bring in
something other than you would normally
bring in and you'll notice immediately a
slight shift and the other person too
and then you keep doing that and over
time and it takes a while but over time
you'll see that the same standard
pattern that you unconsciously are
falling into it those around you
begins to shift and that's what they
care about the rituals create the breaks
over time this shifts how we are
interacting in the world and then over
time what you gain is the ability to
sort of work with these rituals or work
with these patterns such that you're no
longer simply repeating them you're able
to shift them and alter them according
to the circumstances and they would say
that's how over time you learn how to
build better interactions how to build
better relationships really in the least
strong language here how to create very
different worlds because you're acting
in such different ways that you bring
out very different responses from those
around you